secondo voi quanti i giudici sono
fondamentalmente
quelli belli
quelli brutti
e quelli inutili
puoi ma soltanto tu puoi
cdc
che il gioco più valgo zelig - finito
che abbia mai giocato
campeggio italy quando questi critici e
fare un gioco di camion
se non l'avete mai sentito non ti
preoccupare neanch'io fino a poche
settimane fa ero a conoscenza di questo
scempio
ho letto qualche recensione qualche sito
qui e là david ha voluto un emerito
maestra 10
e subito d betitaly
uao
dopo pasti funny gioco tanto da vendere
una delle recensioni
abbastanza
ok guardate vi faccio vedere uno
screenshot del gioco
visto avevano così non sembra poi tanto
male povero giuro
credetemi sulla parola
fa schifo
veramente schifo
ed è con 5 motivi per cui di pizzo
dovrebbe essere mai e poi mai comprato
numero 5
i piccoli errori
di nuovo o di fatali
perché sono staccati dal cavallo
questo non ha senso che ti amo i cani
vanno visti programmatori
puoi il cronometro
mondo di patty costato poco spostare
g2play pixel che la compongono
polietilene non sono molto grande
luccalavoro queste cose si potrebbero
evitare benissimo
numero quattro
il primo impatto
anche qui
non è fondamentale
perugia e quando fate partire il gioco
non appare neanche il logo della casa
produttrice l'uomo dei programmatori
e come se non bastasse
posta rete scherzando
4cam solo 4 cam
solo 4
numero 3
assenza di convertitore
ok sta partendo la gara
pronti via rossi
roma
unione sarda
perché nastri
scusate se pretendo tuo cuore ma quando
compro un video gioco di corse vorrei
che i competitori albero cuccagna già
solo perchè dovrebbero arrivare e
microtomo
numero 2
assenza di fisica guardate qua non c'è
neanche bisogno di commentare
il cane si comporta esattamente come se
non avessi preso proprio persico po'
galeotti fisica di questo
numero 1
il trapasso degli oggetti
la prima volta scugnizzi a praga è
capitato questo
ahahah ma che cacchio
si sono completamente dimenticata di
rende
sono tutti gli oggetti
tutti gli alberi le casette gli
avversari il caccia di ponte
non riesco
immaginami la donna che si fa, poi
eroina cocaina
smartis
e quel sorriso neanche pagare per
giocare questa roba
boom deliro
l'unica cosa decente che ci si può fare
con successo a calci chiavetta tagliarsi
le vene
per favore
non compratelo
dopo averlo prestare e non scaricatelo